AA G GREREATAT T TIMIMEE L LASA
HAHAVEVE A A B BERERTT T TIMIME
FIFINANALL F FOROR T THEHE T THO
GOGO I INN A ANDND B BRIRINGNG
ONON E EITITHEHER R SISIDEDE I
THTHISIS G GREREATAT C CITITYY
NANATITIONONALAL H HOCOCKEKEYY N
THTHEE  SASAMEME B BOAOAT.T.
THTHERERE E ISIS T THEHE C CUPUY
ALALEXEX..OO B BOAOAT.T.
STSTAMAMKOKOSS T TO O THTHE E L
HEHEADAD C COAOACHCH..
ANAND D COCOOPOP I ISS>>>> I I .
P PATAT
WEWENTNT O OVEVER R TOTO R RIGIE
GAGAMEME T T
RARAININDRDROPOPS,S, T THEHEYY O
LELETT T THIHISS F FANAN B BASA
BOBOBBBBY:Y: B BIGIG T TOOOO M .
PAPAULUL:: B BOYOYSS W WILILL L
WEWE S SWIWIMM A ALOLONGNG I IN.
BOBOBBBBY:Y: T THEHE P PARARTYTY